- Aussitôt arrivés, C C C C C Ce
des demandeurs d'asile
fraîchement débarqués
au Royaume-Uni, direction
l'aéroport.
Ils doivent être emmenés
au Rwanda sur un vol nolisé.
Un avion devenu symbole de
britannique.
enenenenenenenenenenenenenenenea
convenu d'envoyer dans ce pays's
migrants qui entrent sur son
territoire de façon irrégulièrer
les côtes britanniques.
Ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à le faire. En fait,
depuis le début de l'année, plus
du Moyen-Orient et du nord de
l'Afrique ont atteint l'Europe,
puis traversé la Manche,
jusqu'au Royaume-Uni. Elles
pourront maintenant être
de là.
Parmi ceux qui s'insurgent
commissaire de l'ONU pour
les réfugiés estime que le
d'asile est un principe
humanitaire fondamental et qu'on
ne peut pas le sous-tr
D'ailleurs, plusieurssssss
de manifestants se sont
rassemblés devant le ministère
de l'Intérieur trtrtrtrtrtrtrtre
la politique du gouvernement
britannique.
"Notre pays" dit-elle, "a les
ressources nécessaires pour
prendr
D'ultimes demandes pour clouer
l'avion au sol ont été
Boris Johnson demeure
critiques, convaincu que la
stratégie permettra d'endigu
le flot de réfugiés.
- Le gouvernement rwandais
prom l l l l l l lui, que ceux
qui arrivent seront en sécurité.
PHILIPPE HABINSHUTI, secrétaire,
éréréréréréréréréréréréréréréréz
la situation des réfugiésndndndz
que leurs droits sont garantis
par les lois rwandaises.
c c c c c c c cette auberge
de Kigali, construite en 2014
pour accueillir des réfugiésmims
d'asile du Royaume-Uni.AIAIAIAIe
adjoint, gouvernement du Rwanda
- yeyeyeyeyeyeyeyeyeyeyeyeyeyeyr
une solution à ce problème
s s s s s s s s longtemps.
Un problème qui prend les vies
des gens, en traversant lee e es
humains.
- Le Rwanda obtiendra également
une compensation de 190 millio
de dollars de la part de
Londres. Ces expulsions auront
cours pendant au moins c
Ici Sébastien Des